we have a choice to make good decisions
and bad decisions that's not going away
anytime soon it's on us it's not him
it's us doing it you got to go through
it and pay the price 88 of SMP 500
companies their largest shareholder is
either State Street Vanguard BlackRock
why does God allow pain and suffering
and evil to exist in this world
although before we go into that you
might have noticed that our intro today
was on fire it was so good the
background music was crazy and you're
probably thinking to yourselves holy
moly Graham where did you get that music
well thankfully your sponsor epidemics
so no joke guys we've been subscribed to
epidemic sound for over three years now
and we use them across multiple channels
on a regular basis and they're our go-to
for copyright free music as a Creator
having copyright free music is crucial
and epidemic is the only place we trust
to have the exact type of music or sound
effects we're looking for they have a
massive library of over 40 000 tracks
and 90 000 sound effects and they work
with carefully selected artists and give
them a fair 50 50 split on streaming
revenue and that's why their business
model is an easy one to support my
favorite thing about epidemic is their
ear feature which works as an extension
of the find similar feature allowing you
the ability to highlight a specific part
of the track and search for music that
sounds similar their personal plan is
ideal for Content creators since it
covers most platforms including YouTube
Facebook Instagram twitch and podcasts
so click the link down Down Below in the
description and user code ich to get a
free 30-day trial and also everything
you post during your trial period is
even protected if you cancel guys it's
free there's literally no risk try it
out with code ich I guarantee you'll
love it and now with that said let's get
back to the podcast so Pat thank you so
much for coming back on it's been almost
exactly a year that you were on the last
time yeah of course I love the work you
guys are doing so you were just on Rogan
too yeah the second time right yes which
is absolutely incredible like that is
that is the Hallmark of being basically
at this point a very important and
impactful person can you walk us through
how that invitation went how the
experience went and you're also very
gracious to give him a bunch of very
thoughtful gifts on the on the podcast
well to me Joe's the goat you know in
the space of if you look at the wall
right there the wall of fame and all the
names that we have there with Elvis
Tupac JFK Marilyn Monroe Frank Sinatra
Tiger Woods Kobe Tom Brady Ali Dave
Chappelle Cena Michael Jordan M Joe
Rogan I think Jose go to what he does
the last three years he showed it was
more than just entertainment it's
enlightenment
he's getting people to think he he was I
think one of the most if not the most
super necessary voice
uh the last three years but in regards
to how it happened I mean I've been
following Joe for a while I'm a fan of
following Joe's content and I messaged
him a few years ago we were just just
complimenting on the work he's doing
about a year and a half after that he
messaged me says hey Pat I want to do a
podcast with you I went out and this
time around it was more around me
wanting to give him a gift after he
opened up his new comedy club and if
you've not been to this Comedy Club this
was a movie theater before the place is
sick it's insane the behind the scenes
the rooms the weights set up uh
everything has a message and he's got
the wall from back in the days the
people he bought it from there's a whole
story to it there's two different clubs
that goes at the same time he performs
there I think three times a week two
times uh uh on the nights but three
times a week and uh this time it was
just hey if you're coming to give me the
gifts let's do another podcast to get
I'd love to and boom it led to the
conversation that it did that's
fantastic I heard he only has four
employees right now running the entire
podcast it's not a lot of employees so
four or five employees facilities let me
tell you the facility is insane you know
we we came he gave us a tour to back and
Vinnie accidentally steps on the floor
where they practice Jiu Jitsu Joe's like
what are you doing when he takes his
foot off and you see all the artwork
just visualize I would say a hundred two
hundred pieces of art laying against the
wall because he has no more room for
wall are you serious yes it's a it's a
good fish it's a massive facility
full-blown gym he's got a room just
purely for archery and then his guys are
there you talk to his guys they love
working for you absolutely love uh
working for him but it's an incredible
facility so it's interesting going on
different podcasts because I was on
yours yesterday and I was shocked at the
amount of research and the attention to
detail that you put into these podcasts
how much goes into that prior great
question so it depends so for example
for the first I don't know eight years
of me doing podcasts I'm the researcher
nobody researches for me so I'm the guy
that's reading the ball I'm doing
this I'm doing that I'm reading the
watching the videos taking notes I have
a format of how I take notes and whether
I start off with facts then I go to
topics and I go to questions I want to
ask that is the format I like having
facts and I like having topics and
issues and then I go to questions that I
want to ask and then now we have a whole
research team that gives us content you
know whether if it's if I'm interviewing
somebody and it's more of a
valuetainment interview it's just more
stuff that's related to you and then
other items that I may want to bring up
to get your opinion on that maybe we
haven't heard your comment on yeah
there's a lot of preparation I'm sure
you saw we now have 74 full-time
employees that are working at the
entertainment a part of it is with the
Consulting from consulting firm is
growing uh extremely rapidly right now
minute are apt right now you know our
app right now we got 70 000 downloads
the last couple months with minute where
how familiar with minute what it does
have you I got a 10 minute pitch and I
downloaded it okay so minute is think
about uh seven years ago or so lawyer of
mine I talked to we had a seven minute
call he charges me for 30 minutes and I
call him up and I said why do you charge
me for 30 minutes we had a seven minute
call he says that's what lawyers do I
mean it's roll up I said not to 30
minutes he said well you know what do
you want me to do about I said you got
to charge me for seven minutes says I
can't do that I said what are you worth
by the minute he says no lawyer charges
by the minute
I said what if there is a technology
where I get to pay for people's time by
the minute so that's when we came up
with do you have a minute to connect
let's connect connect is the app so on
minute if I send the DM to somebody if I
want to get a question answered by
somebody most people don't respond back
to DMS about 90 of DMS get unanswered on
my neck you're gonna get an answer back
because you're paying Graham 200 for a
question he responds back you make 80
percent of that my next keeps 20 of it
if they want to see a video being
responded back from me in a video format
answering the question hey Graham you
run a YouTube channel with 4 million
subscribers a video maybe 400 but if I
want to do a 15 minute face time with
you you get to pick and choose what you
want to charge about a minute 50 bucks a
minute you do face time your face is up
here their faces down here it's done
well so we have a whole team from an act
then we have Product Development
Division and then we have our Cutters
editors shredders we have our production
team here we have the folks that are
running our Cigar Lounge our buildings
the next projects that we're working at
about to buy 10 acres to build a campus
that we'll be doing our docs movies all
that stuff so it's grown I think within
a year year and a half we'll be at
around 250 employees if our HR Team
Speed can catch up we'll be at 120
employees right now I hear Andrew Tate
is doing quite well on there Andrew Tate
did very well there I want to say their
first month they made a hundred thousand
dollars on minute oh my gosh yes I think
they the 93 000 occur it may be between
90 to 100 000 their money on minute you
can go ask questions from them on
manectrist and Tate but you can ask
questions of Chas palm and Terry can ask
questions from bodybuilders can I ask
questions from Consultants those who
raise money it's a lot of different
people yeah and you also recently
interviewed Andrew Tate for the second
time yes 14 million views in one month
which is absolutely astounding I know
for that podcast extra amounts of
research went into it can you walk us
through maybe like the prior three days
before that podcast great question so
here's what we do when we do big
interviews it is extra amount of
research that we do you're looking at
topics issues questions current events
but you're looking at top three five
angles you can't be a you know regular
person that's asking the same exact
questions give me the keys to success or
give me the keys so tell me what
happened here
it has to be angles if your angles
aren't unique no one's interested people
are interested in unique angles right
when I get interviewed on different
podcasts I'm like okay here we go again
this is another question that's penis
that's been asked a million times right
when we did the podcast lifetime last
time a lot of Clips took off for you
guys because you guys did the right job
asking questions to get content that
maybe hadn't been heard before that's
what the audience wants to see right so
with when we got to Romania the night
before I don't know how many hours it
was I would say we sat there at a table
for six hours
to prep on what angles to take with the
interview and when we did the interview
we were all going on probably a couple
hours of sleep and uh it was done we
stayed with them till 12 o'clock one
o'clock in the morning but yes you're
looking at Angles and I'm not only
interviewing him so I interviewed Andrew
and right after us with Andrew we went
to Tristan without a break so it's boom
boom the university seven hours of doing
interviews yeah back to back to back but
uh yes lots of preparation when what
angle did you settle on for the Andrew
Tay interview and what other angles were
you thinking about so BBC to me Mr Mark
with him when they came out trying to do
a gotcha interview they look
disrespectful they look like clowns to
be honest with you and they look like
Hypocrites meaning you have a guy
who is working for your organization
who texted a minor and followed a minor
on Twitter at 15 years old the guy ends
up becoming a
intern for you then you end up hooking
up with this 19 year old kid whatever
age he was when he did you're married
for 27 years with two daughters then he
tells the story of what happened with
you that's public you step away some are
saying that you get together with this
boy when he was underage or what
happened to it the interview that's done
with BBC with this guy and they say so
you've had a rough week how are you
feeling you know that's the opening
question of a guy that followed another
man on Twitter a boy 15 years old on
Twitter right and what's the first
question with Tate are you rape
see when you do stuff like that you lose
credibility this is why people don't
trust mainstream media today back in the
days Ted Turner when he started CNN he
said news was the talent it was the news
that you looked up to today it's flipped
it's not the news it's the anchor it's
the individual right you used to watch
CNN and they would give the news to you
you used to watch Walter Cronkite we
just got news that our president very
unfortunate news today President John F
Kennedy has been boom it was just news
being given to you right the news what
we wanted to get so a lot of these guys
have Mr Mark unfortunately unfortunately
for BBC CNN MSNBC many of them the
market is changing people want long form
they want to talk to human beings they
want to be asked questions that those
guys are thinking about not what you're
thinking about what are they thinking
about you could ask a question you're
thinking about but what do they want at
they don't have access to me or they
don't have access to Tate they want
those questions so if you ask the
questions that they're wondering
and people are going to sit there and
say that's exactly what I've been
thinking about this in terms how is it
that BBC asked this and then so all
these different angles you think about
and then you try to be fair to like even
yesterday's interview would be vacuumed
the town hall that we did opening
question was what world economic Forum
it's not a friendly question it's a
question hey you're tied to World
economic Forum what do you think about
this hey you're Indian is a part of what
you're trying to do to go away from
China your relations with India is that
kind of like trying to help your
Homeland are you vaccinated did you take
the vaccine you heard at the end what he
said right it was kind of uncomfortable
right hey how about how you going to
handle this you're 37 years old you're
38 years old you've never been there
before how are you going to hire people
want to have those questions being asked
at the same time why do you think you're
doing so well why do you think as a
young age you know your you know Twitter
account has grown the way that is and
your competitors are not why do you
think America's file on your content so
much we need to kind of give a little
bit of both sides even the viewer
question about religion I was like I was
like Heather right the lady that asked
the question yeah
very impressive question I knew it uh it
knocked vivec back what do you think
about his answer though I thought it was
great I thought it was great he's a
great he's a great speaker of course
what do you believe him with his answer
do you actually believe him I do I do as
well but here's the thing I also I tend
to fall for stuff like this
you can trust me I'm honest you know
like
yes about it no it's true it happens
time and time again and so with him I'm
like this is the guy this is the one I
trust yeah so you know it could just be
me being naive you know but you know you
know what it is as well there's a part
of it where he's here last night with us
is there shaking hands I said where's
your wife at his wife was doing a
surgery last night she's a surgeon while
he's here he's got two kids the guy's
worth a few hundred million dollars
started a company raised 2.2 billion
it's valued at nine billion dollars
today he doesn't need to do this he
lives an incredible life but he's still
working his wife is still working let me
get this straight your wife is still
working while you're worth this much
money it's more than just money when
you're doing something like that so it's
not like we're above you we're better
than you there was a good feeling about
now we're gonna see it's going to be
rough competing with everybody else but
it was interesting talking to him again
the point being
you got to ask all the questions that
are the good questions as well as the
tough questions and then let the
audience decide now let me ask you this
do you think that's a bit of an ego play
because it seems like sometimes when
people have a certain amount of money
then they go for power and that might be
in the form of going to congress senate
presidency do you feel like that's maybe
a thing that's going on I think what
you're doing some could say is an eagle
play sure how many more subscribers do
you need Graham you got four and a half
million Mr Graham right why do you need
to get to 10 million I'm running a small
YouTube channel out of Arkansas with 2
800 subscribers and I'm happy although
before we go into that as you probably
noticed one of the things that we really
enjoy is coming up with fun ideas and
then turning them into a reality in fact
that's how the podcast even came to be
what if you had an amazing business idea
but you didn't have access to business
partners like us well don't worry
today's sponsor Shopify is a better
business partner than Jack will ever be
Shopify is the e-commerce platform
that's already transformed millions of
businesses worldwide you can also
customize your online store with
flexible templates and Powerful tools so
whether you're selling satin sheets
using their in-person POS system or
offering organic olive oil online
they've got you covered so you might
also know about my coffee
bankrollcoffee.com that I sell online
and that's been hosted by Shopify for
the last three years and they've been
absolutely fantastic they're the only
company I even considered going with
because they're that good and also
believe it or not before I worked with
Graham on this podcast I had like four
Shopify stores they were also the only
platform I ever considered to sell
things online what set Shopify apart is
their ability to turn random internet
browsers into buyers with the internet's
best converting checkout and with the
single dashboard you can manage order
shipping and payments from anywhere in
the world Shopify Powers 10 of all
e-commerce in the United States and
they're quickly turning into a global
Force supporting Brands like all birds
rothies in Brooklyn and then over 170
countries so sign up for just a one
dollar a month trial period at
shopify.com ich again that shopify.com
ich to take your business to the next
level shopify.com ich thank you so much
Shopify and back to the episode I
created a a flow with myself kind Mario
we sat there and we said what percentage
of a human being being selfish or
selfless is good for society okay let's
kind of look at both sides is a person
who is a hundred percent selfless good
for society if you're 100
selfless meaning everything you do is
for others are you good for society
is good for society I'm trying to think
at what level does being selfish benefit
others if the if the point is to help
others at what point is being selfish
help so picture somebody who's 100
selfless they do everything for who
everybody else right so there's an
element of Conformity there's an element
of trying to please everybody there's an
element of constantly worried about what
other people think those types of people
don't typically do net positive good for
society because the first thing we want
you to do is we want you to take care of
yourself okay a few things with me I
don't mind if you smoke weed I'll shake
your hand I don't mind if you smoke
cigars I'll shake your hand if you smoke
cigarettes I can't deal with it okay
when I shake someone's hand to smoke
cigarettes I go like this I'm like give
me a flip and break I'll go like this
too next time I don't like cigarettes
right if you don't take care of your
body and you smell you can't be around
me too much I got a big nose and I can
smell everything okay I can smell if you
took a shower I can smell if you don't
brush your teeth I can smell it and I
don't like it I ran a sales team and one
of the things happened when you run a
sales team you have to have a lot of
awkward conversations so when a young
guy gets started and you want to sell I
would sit there and I would say hey you
don't yet have credibility to have beard
if you're going to be selling Insurance
you got to kind of fix your hair a
little bit you got to get your cut on
the side a little bit you got to shave
if you're going to sit in front of other
people asking them to sell their million
out of home with you you got to dress up
better now you guys are on a YouTube
channel you don't care what I think
about you there's an element that that's
your look you got like the Steve Jobs
look but I would sit down I would tell
guys and I would say hey Johnny yes
do you know you smell
you're serious yeah you smell bro and
it's not good and about 20 people have
brought it up to me and here's what I
want to do with you do you want to
continue smelling or do you want to do
something about it I want to do
something about it I don't know if you
have a father figure in your life that's
having this conversation with you but
I'm going to have it with you and we're
doing it privately behind closed doors
so you don't need to be embarrassed but
I'm hoping for the rest of your life no
one ever needs to have this conversation
with you fair fair let me give you the
starter kit here what do you use when
you shower at night what soap do you use
what shampoo do you use tell me what
razor to use can you actually show it to
me go on the website and show me what
you buy you use that kind of shampoo are
you sure how do you wash yourself do you
blow your blow dry your body afterwards
do you blow dry down here down here down
here in your toes because that's where
fungus is how do you blow dry what do
you do here's what I do okay how do you
shave do you shave up do you shave
sideways do you shave down what are you
doing Pat no one's talking about this
kind of stuff I'm 23 years old I totally
get it but it's my job I'll do it the
first time but it happens second time
you got to figure something enough for
yourself because sales is not going to
work out so here's an option for you
with deodorant okay here's the
toothpaste here's the toothbrush here's
the spray here's a cologne go start
working on this this is a soap you can
use this is the ax you can use I would
give them the starter kit and they would
come back because if you're 100 selfless
you don't really care about you know
taking care of yourself all you care
about is well you're hurting everybody
else now let's flip the question do you
think a person that's 100 selfish is a
net positive to society no do you think
more than 100 selfless
makes you think yeah so what is it think
about a person that's 100 selfish what
do they typically do make money great
that's a positive to society what else
does a hundred percent uh selfish do
they take care of themselves right
they're clean they probably don't donate
right that's fine volunteer but the
Mohan selfless one probably doesn't make
any money because that guy doesn't have
any dreams or Vision or goals so when
you think about this element and you say
do you think vivek's doing it for ego
and all this stuff I think you're doing
it for ego sure but I don't think it's
100 so the number we found that's
reasonable that's a good amount to be
that a guy's still driving is 70 30. if
70 of you is driving for your goal your
dreams your vision 30 is for him the
people around your audience yeah you're
a net positive because you're constantly
in search of something if somebody is 50
50 they're typically a good advisor
because they don't want anything from
you you know the only thing they want
from you is a little bit of credit to
say hey John thank you for that price so
that is an element where anybody that
runs they're typically around the seven
seventy percent selfish thirty percent
what would you say you are I think I'm
around the 65 35 70 because for me so my
wife and I when we have a conversation
about vision
and I say to her I said babe if you want
somebody
to be home every night at six o'clock to
have dinner I'm not the guy if you want
somebody to be in town every single week
for the entire year I'm not the guy for
you if you want somebody that's going to
sit there and say oh my God I'm so sorry
I'm this I'm that I'm this I'm not that
guy I'm not compromising my vision
because that vision is a commitment I
have to my father my Heritage my family
and my God I'm not compromising that
Vision I'm not compromising my values
and principles these are things that I'm
fighting for if you're okay with that
let's roll if you're not let me
introduce you to some of my friends that
may be in better match for you than me
this is when we were dating okay so if I
see relationships husband and wife I'll
typically talk about this and you know
I'll talk to someone I'll say oh my God
this guy's a real good talent I like him
a lot so let's just say you want to have
a good meeting tonight and you leave
like Pat I'm on fire we're gonna go do
this and let's just say we have a god
conversation or we have a health
conversation or we have a political
conversation and you're like this is
fantastic that's a good point and then
you go home and your wife says you
explain to babe you won't even believe
what I just I was over here Vivek was
talking and Patrick was saying this and
yeah that's a good point that's stupid
that doesn't make any sense you know
you're not that you're not like them
that's not you you don't think so babe
no those are just a bunch of egotistical
people
yeah you know what I thought about that
yeah I think you're right babe I love
you and you go to sleep versus you go
babe I saw this debate and I've said
Vivek and Patrick yeah babe that statue
that's stupid those are egotistical
people what are you talking about babe
yeah those are egotistic these are
people that only care about themselves
I'm sorry babe you care about you take
care of yourself I'm glad you do I do I
love the fact that they're driven I like
being around people that are doing this
they inspired me tonight babe you know
we want to live a different life baby I
don't know what life you want to live
this is a life I want to live I'm hoping
you're brought in see if you can't have
that conversation you don't have a
backbone then you're the one that's
going to be bitter 5 10 15 20 30 years
down the line looking back saying I
compromise my vision for this girl and
now you're upset at her you're blaming
the wife you're seeing your kids and
you're saying if you only know what your
mom did to me it's not the wife's fault
it's your fault because the way
you compromise
your vision that you have for what you
want to do that God put on you you know
if there's something you keep thinking
about that's a vision that's important
to you and if you can't have the
backbone to pursue it then it's not a
last appointment issue you're not fully
committed to what you want to do you can
be fickle and people can change your
mind constantly I notice God is a topic
that comes up frequently with you what
role does God have in your life and do
you think that everybody needs a
relationship with God to some capacity
or could some exist without a
relationship with God everybody has a
god
okay my God for
from 14 years old to 25 was women
they were my God okay it was everything
I wanted I couldn't get enough of it I
wanted all of them I wanted every
ethnicity every background in every
place in every Club I wanted them all
okay some kids their goddess video games
some people their goddess food some
people their God is the amount of likes
they get on social media everybody has a
God so there's no such thing as you look
at these people who believe in God they
need God they're weak that's what they
are no no look at you who your God is
your god is porn
your God is women your God is money your
goddess everybody has so there's no such
thing as I don't I have a gobble you
don't have a God you have a God as well
I said we have a different god so let's
set that part aside about who has a God
who doesn't have a god for me
you know my entire life I had a big uh
conflict with the man upstairs because
you know when you're living in Iran and
your mom and dad have taped the windows
because when the explosion of a bomb
comes you don't want the window to you
just want it to fall and it doesn't hurt
the kids and I'm just my bed is right
underneath seven eight windows in in
Iran street name is hojat and we're
right there that's not a good
environment to be raised in you're going
outside you've seen holes in the ground
and the places used to play right across
the street you're hearing this whistling
sound and your parents get divorced
twice in 20 years they get married your
sister is born to get divorced then they
get remarried then you're born then they
get a divorce and the visual that I had
as a kid when every night on the fourth
floor my dad would walk up at 8 30 and I
would see his head first step boom boom
I knew my dad is he had run up to the
door open it up give him a hug that the
last time I I experienced that I was 10
years old boom gone I don't see that
head climbing at 8 30 animal when he
come up from work it was the best moment
of my day that's the last time that
happened the only vacation I ever took
as a family with my Mom and Dad we went
to a city called esfahan and Estefan is
like an old city with a lot of different
things there's a song by a man named
Moen he sings a song called
them I'll sit there in my backyard and
I'll listen to that song for two hours
straight it just he's saying
my heart wants to return to esfahan okay
my heart wants to return to S1 because
my entire family was together it was me
my sister my mom and my dad okay so then
you go to Germany at a refugee camp for
two years there's no father figure you
don't know what to do you're
experiencing bullying fighting out there
you know fighting with afghanis
pakistanis Germans you know all these
other people from different ethnicities
like who are you from Iran you're in our
country here right now that's exactly
why Germany is being ruined because
they're letting too many of you here and
maybe they were partly right and why
would why are we coming in your Homeland
you know we're dealing with our own mess
and then eventually we'll make it to the
states and I go to the Army and I get
I'm like don't even talk to him about
God or anything and then eventually
I realized with a couple moments a man
give me a Bible uh when I was in the
Army and he said you need this Bible
more than I do his parents gave him that
Bible December 24 1974 I have the Bible
until today in my office so I don't know
man you know I like office I like Rumi
these uh famous poets from Iran and Rumi
had a poet I'll butcher it but you can
kind of see how he says where you know
God uses human beings as a flu to sink
through which means in a way God talks
to you and I through people and then one
day A friend of mine who was a tough guy
in La we went to school together him and
I both had a 1.8 GPA
and neither one of us were going to do
anything so when we went to college and
we're at Glendale Community College me
and Armond were the ones that told you
you're an idiot if you go to class we
would make fun of you we were those
friends we'd be like look at these
idiots they're going to class what are
you going to do going to class man who
cares about a college degree stay here
let's play spades let's play Hulk stay
for another hour and we would influence
kids to drop out of their class that was
us okay so I go to the Army he does what
he does this is the same guy that one
time punched a guy in the face with a
brass knuckles he punched a guy in the
face breaks the guy's jaw was telling
the story to you guys he breaks the
guy's jaw the guy can't eat he's eating
out of a straw for 30 days and one day
he tells the story to me the father
comes to his
house he knocks on the door opens the
door the father's looking at him saying
I'm not here to do anything to you I'm
only here for you to see the pain of a
father going through for what you did to
my son and the dad is crying
he says I don't ever want you to feel
the pain I'm I'm feeling right now when
I watch my son John I can't talk to my
son I'm in pain and you brought that
pain to my son he says that day messed
me up right guilt all this stuff and it
was I go to the Army I come back 24
years old and I go to rafi's place and I
said so how are you doing this as well
Jesus has changed my life I'm like I'm
thinking he's joking with me he says no
I'm telling you I said come on man what
are you talking about you yeah stop it
you're pulling a prank because we were
both pranksters big pranksters he said
I'm telling you you got to come to Bible
study with me so I go to Bible study
with them Friday night
in uh paznaz with this guy named Mano
and would sit there from six o'clock in
the morning at night till two o'clock in
the morning we're debating and I'm just
trying to debate debate debate debate
debate anyways eventually I make a
decision I become baptized January I
think it's 21st of all four and I
realized I don't want to live my life
alone
I'm not alone right now I'm around you
guys
when you're together you're around each
other you're around your girl you're not
alone right but you're going to be alone
who do you talk to when you're alone I
want a relationship with God when I'm
alone because if if my vision is Big of
what I want to do in my life for me to
think I can do it by myself that is so
arrogant and it's so much pressure on an
individual when things don't go your way
sometimes you need to just say look man
I'm going to pray like it's up to you
but I'm going to work like it's up to me
there's a man named Greg that told me
this 20 years ago and there's so much
truth behind it right God has played an
incredible role in my life
um I'm I'm a guy that's very honored and
grateful for the life that he's given me
I look at my kids faces and I tell Dylan
I say Dylan do you realize I can't
imagine life never meeting you he says
what do you mean Daddy I said
June July of 2002
I'm at Thomas Mack Center with Lou Holt
speaking I'm at that event with my
girlfriend sitting to my right and a
girl named Jennifer sitting to my uh my
left is my girlfriend a girl sitting to
my right a girl named Jennifer we're all
the way in the back Lewis is speaking I
said if I don't go to that event that
day
the girl on my left ends up becoming an
ex the girl on my right five and a half
years later when we wrote single becomes
my girlfriend she's your mother I would
have never met you
I cannot imagine life never meeting you
Dylan never meeting Patrick Tico never
meeting Sena or never meeting Brooklyn
if that meeting and appointment never
happens I'm devastated that meeting is
scheduled by the man upstairs so for me
uh if your vision's big if you want to
do something massive with your life you
almost need Faith but if you don't
believe in a god trust me you have a God
you just don't know what it is yet now
I'm curious because I've heard a lot of
different answers to this and I want to
know your opinion on this sure but why
does God allow pain and suffering and
evil to exist in this world you know
it's a good question you ask it's a
question you know I ask for a big part
of my life with the things that I saw
that's the Free Will part man it's our
choice he doesn't make us do anything he
leaves it to you and I on what we do and
how we live our lives if God was a
micromanager that would be a different
story he's not he's like look here's
what you've been given with here's the
talents we're giving you here's the life
go do good with it and find a way to be
better to my guys my people my kids and
then you get to choose to make bad
decisions okay he doesn't now if you go
back and
you know some can say well you know
that's When sin happened Adam Eve Apple
that's when we started sending prior to
that we were this we were that great we
have a choice to make good decisions and
bad decisions that's not going away
anytime soon it's on us it's not him
it's us doing it so what I heard also I
love that answer but what I heard also
that I really liked is that if he showed
himself every single time evil occurred
and let's say like cancer was given to a
child or something like that
then it wouldn't be Faith anymore it
would just be fact it would be what is
and the power about belief is that it's
faith and you need to be able to believe
in something that is in fact because
like I said it would just be what is let
me ask you a question was your father in
your life growing up as a kid he was
okay how old were you the first time you
got bullied I wasn't really bullied that
much when I was did you ever get into a
fist fight no never I was a pacifist I
would always like run away shy away from
that did you ever get bullied yes how
old were you the first time you got
bullied
kindergarten preschool people call me
graham cracker graham crackers oh well I
would get both yeah I would get bullied
like that sure people because I'm Jack
and my last name Selby so they
abbreviate jackass
so so how often did your dad go and beat
those guys up never why not why would
you let that happen to a son because
they're minors I never told my parents
but let me ask you another question when
you grow up did a girl break your heart
when you were 18 years old I had my
heart broken a little bit okay did your
mom go and slap her in the face and say
how dare you break my son now why
wouldn't she do that how dare she break
your heart why would a mother let their
son's heart be broken what kind of a
mother do you have you know is that a
good mother of course it's a good mother
you have to go through it okay you got
to go through it and pay the price have
you done any wrongdoings you ever got
caught stealing you ever got caught
cheating on tests you ever got caught
doing something I was wrong you ever got
suspended you ever got referrals you
ever gone to you know something you
shouldn't have done yeah and
it hurts your parents you know
one day my son
um is uh in in soccer practice this is
my oldest
and
he calls my wife calls and says babe
they just kicked him out of the camp
so what do you mean babe they kicked
them out of the camp
[Music]
so what are you talking about babe why
would they kick him out of the camp he
knocked the kid out
I said what do you mean he knocked the
kid out in front of the coach he punched
him the kid fell he knocked him out they
said he can't come back here anymore
so when I hear my son in the back
screaming
screaming dad you know I'm not afraid of
the truth you call me honest Tico you
say I'm like honest ape I'm not afraid
of the truth I said what happened he
punched me first
is it Tico I'm telling you he punched me
first I said come on I said put the
phone on you in his face and put the
phone on his head I said I'll go fight
for you
but you better be telling me the truth
I'm telling you the truth and you see
the tears coming down
so no problem all good
I call the owners I said hey I heard you
guys kick my son out we did he punch a
kid in the uh and he knocked him out and
parents were right there and we we can't
go back we can't have that kind of
behavior I said you guys have cameras
there we do I want you to go watch the
camera and see who hit who first
okay
how soon can you get back to me give us
an hour in practice sense no problem two
hours nobody calls three hours they call
me
how you doing good so what happened your
son is right he got punched first
and he reacted and he knocked him out
we've asked the other kid to be gone for
a week your son is welcome to come back
but I personally wanted to call you to
apologize I said you know to apologize
to me I don't care you didn't offend me
you need to apologize to my son I'm
gonna bring him in and I need you to
have a conversation with him I take I
take him to practice his mom typically
takes him I take him to practice I said
go ahead
the guy coaches a Venezuelan phenomenal
classy guy gets on his and he says son I
just want to tell you we messed up you
were in the right we were in the wrong
okay and he goes in and he plays this
game and he does his practice and all
this stuff it's a great practice that he
has but you can tell like somebody had
his back right now in life
sometimes when you're right
and somebody does something to you it
may take five years till you get your
Redemption 10 years 15 years till you
get your Redemption but these are the
types of moments where you know at times
we have to go through our mess at times
God's going to use somebody to come and
defend you and at times No One's Gonna
show up sometimes you're gonna like
you're like I never told my parents
sometimes you know if you're not praying
talking to God he doesn't know who to
send you ain't praying sometimes you
just gotta the best way I started
praying is the final I just my first
prayer was like this at 18 years old
I said God I don't believe you exist I
think it's fake I think it's for people
that are weak but I'm going to pray and
if you're out to great
I'll see what happened here with the
prayer if not I'm just going to talk to
you that's how my prayers were for three
years I prayed like that so the
exercising of praying if somebody's
watching this you're doing it yourself
you don't have to tell people you're
praying test it and see what happens go
do that for about three six months see
what happens and then test it for
yourself if it doesn't happen it is what
it is but at least take the first step
to start praying to a god you don't
believe exist and see if he responds now
I'm curious in your son's case going
back to that fight
I was always taught that if someone were
to hit you you don't hit back and you
should walk away go tell a teacher or
something like that how do you balance
that and
standing up for yourself and punching
back harder
if you get punched first those are the
standards you're gonna have to choose
when you have a kid but to me
think about the profile of a bully what
is the profile of a bully
the profile of a bully is he finds
targets
and what does a bully theme weak targets
targets that he's not afraid of targets
that back down targets that don't come
back at you right do you watch UFC at
all not really do you like boxing at all
I like watching and I don't typically
though no no do you watch any UFC any of
that yeah casually watch it what do you
think about what do you think about
fighting not for me but I appreciate the
sport does it entertain you at all or no
it does it does entertain you do you
know 90 of these guys when they started
fighting why they started fighting they
got bullying they got bullied and look
where they are now so I mean you know
there's an element of that where if
somebody comes and Bullies you once and
you don't do anything Second Time Around
third time around fourth time around now
you have a reputation you know what the
reputation is you can bully them I
remember when I started my own insurance
company September 23rd of 09 a month
later I get sued
400 page lawsuit comes to me okay from a
400 billion dollar company massive
company and they sue me and they sue
five other people which means we have to
represent five pieces like they sue me
only we'll have to get illegal for me
they want to make sure everybody
depletes their savings and they skip
scare the crap out of everybody and all
the insurance companies didn't want to
give me contracts that they're like
Patrick's got a big lawsuit he's going
to go out of business at that time
I could have either sat there and taken
it from the bully or I had to make sure
they also knew where we stood we had
multiple conversations
the moment they realized where we stood
and we were not going to take clients we
were not going to defame and start
saying this and this and that and you
know they're trashing them and all that
other stuff nope I'm a I'm a guy that
was going to wait to see what you say
about me then I'm going to come at you
hard but if you don't say anything about
me I'm not going to say anything bad
about you at all we're good to go we
move on so he finally said look man if
you don't say anything we won't say
anything no problem good to go so we go
We Roll I don't at all talk about the
company I don't at all trash nothing if
you go ask any of our sales guys did Pat
ever train on trashing other insurance
company they'll tell you Pat's never
trained on that never got 45 000 agents
Nationwide then one day I get a letter
from the CEO of this company
cease and this letter there was an image
going around on Facebook that a guy
created named Tony and he was comparing
our comp to them I don't like doing
stuff like that but he did this and then
it went viral and the CEO sends me a
letter and it's comparing our company
says well you know we just want to let
you know we paid this much commission
last year this much is this much that
and you need to have your designers not
put this out there and I'm like okay no
problem comes to my house so now I'm
getting ready to send a response back to
him with a letter to his home office
then all of a sudden I noticed 50 100
people post that letter on social media
from their company and these are all
leaders so I noticed the letter wasn't
just sent to me he sent it to me and to
all their vice presidents to say we are
not back in Donna we're gonna bully this
guy no problem now I have to react at 2
30 in the morning I react with a letter
I write open letter Facebook post that
you gotta go read okay and I post the
image and I say first of all I want to
say whoever created this image I want to
thank them because it took us seven
years to have a meeting together I've
received many different love letters in
my life but yours is one of my favorite
love letters of all time I thought this
was only going to me but since you chose
to send this to every other leader in
your company I figured it was better for
me to write an open letter to you and I
went through the whole thing I said I
notice you golf three four five times a
week at these two different country
clubs I noticed what your work is I
notice what you're doing as a person
who's a Founder we work at a different
level I've noticed your company got
started in such and such year the
founder got their insurance license in
1977 I was born in 1978. I wish I could
sell insurance as an infant but I
couldn't I got out of the army and this
and this sometime and I put that out
there that goes viral one guy
he knows who is and I know who you are
creates a burner account and starts
acting like his name is this girl's name
and he accidentally switches again his
name post and then he deletes it so we
know exactly who this guy was he got
caught it was so embarrassing and
beautiful at the same time but you know
what happened in that moment our company
after that post grew 75 percent that
year
because everybody in the company
realized you can't bully us we will
stand up there's different ways to stand
up but if my kid there's a kid in school
that's bullying my kid if my kid's being
bullied First Step you tell them hey
don't do it second step you tell a
teacher if he continues you've been
instructed by your dad to use your
abilities of jujitsu to show him don't
do this again and make sure you do when
there's 20 people around because there
are 20 people will be your publicist
they're going to go tell everybody and
you will not be fighting while you're at
the school so there's these elements
where you have to stand up if you don't
the bully is going to keep showing up I
love the theme of like being a powerful
dad and teaching your son powerful
values I know it was in an interview
that you did recently you were talking
about how wealth goes away after a few
generations and how you actually had a
team that was studying Vanderbilt and a
bunch of other generationally wealthy
people yeah to make sure that this
doesn't happen with your family what did
you find out from these studies and what
strategy are you going to employ to
teach the right things in your children
to make sure that the wealth stays yeah
you know this whole thing got started
when I interviewed this guy I keep
forgetting his name so this guy his job
is
to deal with families that are worth a
hundred million dollars and higher to
make sure their kids turn out well
that's his job think about what an
interesting job that is and he's in
Seattle why is that important Amazon
Microsoft a lot of billionaires a lot of
Hector millionaires definitely a lot of
deca millionaires right and I said what
was the common theme you realized with
when you when you got got there to help
the families what was it Patrick 99 of
the time it's too late they call me once
their kid is already a drug addict they
call me once their kid is already a
alcoholic they call me after they
already got their kids three
Lamborghinis they already gave them you
know flying all over the place on a
private jet it's done there's nothing
you can do about it at that time 20
years ago I read a book called Ultimate
gift I don't know if you've ever read
the book ultimate Guild by Jim Stovall
who I believe is blind and deaf he wrote
this book ultimately give second 100
pages I read it I bought a thousand
copies I sold it to all my guys I said
you guys all got to read it this is the
book of the month the story is about a
guy
who moves to Texas works for this guy
who when he dies the guy leaves them the
land and this guy I think his name is
Rex in the book or rent something like
that the land that he gives to this
employee of his ends up being a land
filled with oil so he strikes oil so he
becomes a billionaire and when this guy
becomes a billionaire
he's got massive accounts companies oil
thousands of employees beautiful big
house properties all over the place and
then he realizes he spoiled everybody he
spoiled his wife his kids everyone his
best friend is his lawyer of 40 years
so he sits with his lawyer and he says
look
I want to do a couple things he says
what's that I want to make a video that
I want you to play the day I die when
everybody shows up to get their
inheritance and I want you to play that
video for them so can we shoot that
video together he says great what do you
think I should say in the video they
make a list spray and the old video
starts right he's talking to them in the
video he says if I ever play this video
it's because I'm dead then he creates 12
other videos so anyways let me first
tell you what the first video is the day
comes when he dies
family shows up
his sons his wife with two young men and
you know all these guys are showing up I
think his daughter with two young men
and you know all these guys are gonna
it's like oh they're smiling all this
hey hey and they're talking to the Lord
because the Lord is the guy he trusted
the most and the lawyer knew everyone's
drug addict you know habits everything
plays the video hi
if you're watching this video it's
because I'm dead let me tell you what
this is all about today
you're here you're happy you're probably
smiling because you're gonna get your
inheritance this is a big day for you
you see them they kind of feel like
uncomfortable but they're smiling and he
says to you my such and such daughter or
son
I'm Gonna Leave You my 600 million
dollar account that I have with you know
my investments
however
you're going to live off the interest
that money is not for you my advisor
makes all the decisions Financial you
don't get to tell them anything what to
do the money is hopefully going to go to
your grandkids if they behave and if you
can show that you can manage this money
well to my other son I'm gonna give my
real estate portfolio whatever half a
billion dollars but guess what
the cleaners have more say about the
house than you do
the property manager has more say than
you do it's kind of going through that
and he says you're going to get this
this the company but you don't get to
run the company my board runs the
company you're not even the chairman of
the board it's just the shares and all
of this is written with the lawyers and
they're going through everybody's pissed
off walking up pissed off walking I'm
pissed off walking out and he says to my
nephew I don't have anything to give you
well one thing you're not going to get a
car you're not going to get a house
you're not going to get stocks you're
the only one here
that I haven't spoiled you're the only
one that has a chance at life what I
have for you is The Ultimate Gift
The Ultimate Gift is going to take 12
months for you to realize what it is
I have 12 videos I've created just for
you
every Tuesday if you choose to find out
what the Ultimate Gift is you come in to
my lawyer my best friend's office he
plays one video you watch the video then
you have 30 days of what you need to do
12 months later you get the Ultimate
gift and you see the nephew is like all
upset you know pissed off he says you're
probably not happy right now and I
understand and you're probably going to
walk at it to see that he's walking out
he says however son I just want to tell
you you have a shot I live in a
fulfilling life if you choose to come
back on Tuesday to find out the Ultimate
gift
that book motivated me I was 25 years
old when I read this book
24 years old when I read this book so
this thought I've been thinking about
for a while you know and so when you
think about some of these families that
did it right they spoiled their kids
they weren't there for their kids they
didn't manage their kids they bought
their kids love with gifts you know it's
like I don't buy gifts for my kids if
you ask my wife how many gifts I bought
for my kids I'm not a guy that buys
gifts for my kids I'll say things like
hey Daddy can we get that Lego that Lego
is 10 bucks hey Daddy can we get that
video again that video game is 20 bucks
hey Daddy can we go buy the new FIFA you
finish Atlas Shrug you'll get it hey
Daddy I want to get a right now uh my uh
youngest son picked up Fountainhead by
himself he's reading he's on page 250 or
something he knows if they finish
Fountainhead and a few other things this
guy's been working on this for two years
they're about to get their tree house
but the Treehouse they've been asking
for four years it's been four years till
they get their tree house what is the
Treehouse if I buy 10 grand 20 grand 50
Grand it's not a lot of money I don't
have a problem with that part but I want
them to earn it everything for me is
with them busting their asses my son's
schedule every day after he gets off
school three to four he swims four to
five is soccer five to six is Jiu Jitsu
six to seven is baseball by the time he
comes home he asked me a question the
other night he says Daddy
do I have a busy schedule or is this a
normal schedule for all kids I said
that's very normal this is because when
I talk to my friends they don't have my
schedule I said they don't want to tell
you the truth everybody has this kind of
a schedule I said but listen here's what
I will tell you so what's that you're a
bit David
I don't care what the Joneses schedule
is I don't care what the Jackson
schedule is this is the big David's
schedule okay and this is the schedule
you're going to go on but Daddy loves
you I'm here for you we're going to
celebrate victories we're going to do
this we're going to do that I think it
has to be something you think about but
even with parenting you can do
everything right and the kid can still
screw up you can do everything right
they still have the choice to make they
can still hook up with whoever they want
to they can still choose to have sex
without a kind of with a girl they met
at a club and get that girl all of these
things are still possible they can still
be tempted on one day they're pissed off
at their daddy
and they walk away and say you're just
too much my girlfriend is right you are
a capitalist all you care about is money
that's your God you don't love us you
could buy me this car you could buy me
the house like the other person is doing
but you are so cheap because all you
care about is your money I know that
moment is coming
I know this coming but I'm good with it
and I'm going to Stand My Ground because
I'm banking by 25 30 if they get through
that ugly phase of hating that the three
phases you got to go through with your
father you idolize you demonize you
humanize I'm in the idolized face right
now the demonized face comes next that's
not gonna be pretty for me but I have to
be stronger enough of a leader to be
able to handle next phase so it's a
tough job but you never know what's
going to happen as long as you prepare
early you got to fight you let them
watch TV go on the internet social media
how do you control that or do you how
everything is structured my kids
so don't have a phone all their phone
all their friends have phones they don't
have phones what are the ages of your
kids just 11972 okay
um in our house when you turn six years
old you have to read 20 pages every day
okay and the books there's steps on what
you go through next and then when you
have to read a serious books like you
know whatever that was something of fire
or you know hunger not a Hunger Games
there's a couple of these books like uh
Harry Potter or you know some of these
serious things that you need to go
through for your imagination to kind of
see the different stuff that's out there
and then you're going to read some real
books when you're nine years old a
thousand page type of books to kind of
go through it but video games there's no
iPad throughout the week zero iPad
throughout the week
Saturday Sundays if you have a c
in your class there is no iPad at all
ever zero if you have one C you get no
iPad not on Saturdays not on Sundays
nothing so my son one of them has a c
guess what there is no iPad for him
however
Saturday Sunday you wake up this morning
my daughter woke up at seven o'clock she
read her book King Daddy I read the book
what'd you learn about it here's what I
learned about the founding fathers I
learned that this I learned that this
and I learned that this President is
this seven-year-old daughter I said
great babe you can go play iPad for an
hour okay because she's made up all her
assignments for the week when it comes
down to uh TV TV if you haven't read you
can't watch TV same thing on the
weekends I pick movies return on we take
turns on movies and all that stuff on
what they can do and that's kind of what
we do with it now let me go to the
seaside I need leverage to get my kids
to get smarter and read the content and
study the material that I want them to
read
I'm watching my son he hasn't played
iPad for three months
and I'm like you're wasting an
opportunity because he doesn't have a
desire to learn he's just waiting for
the C to become a b so he can play iPad
so we got to figure something out that's
here's what we're gonna do
for every documentary you watch that I
choose in our documentary you'll get 30
minutes on the weekends
and this is during summer season so
guess what you watch 40 documentaries
you got some hours but if you watch
three documentaries this week you got an
hour and a half over the weekend so my
sons have watched the entire man in the
arena Captain the Last Dance
Pele all these documentaries you know
the plane that went missing JFK
assassination all of this stuff for
their brain to be vibrating at what
happened here what do you think happened
here what do you think happened there
but that's the system we've created you
have to exercise you have to take care
of your body but that's the system how
do you balance between being a free
thinker an entrepreneur who forges their
own path or having a very structured
outline because For Me growing up my
parents were very much you could do what
you want to do and we're not going to
get in the way of that if you decide
that you just wanna do nothing all
weekend you could do that if you decide
you want to be productive you could do
that and I feel like that sort of
Freedom allowed me as an adult to do
what I thought was best in the moment
even if it's not structured or what
everyone else is doing how do you
balance the two yeah that's that's good
for you uh kudos to you for doing that
that doesn't work out most of the time
with a lot of people uh as an outlier as
a exception to the rule that's great now
think about this give me one system that
produced a lot of great leaders without
any structure give me any system hear me
out what I say like if you if you're
going to a place where they produce
leaders right
by the way this thing is structured here
just so you know everything is elon's
got the whole system on what he's doing
he runs a show yeah okay last night for
things not nothing happened I didn't
even think about AV last night and
typically when I'm doing stuff I'm
thinking about why don't I think about
AV because things were scored away with
him he's running the show he's telling
people what to do their systems here
when we came in to walk through the
preparation the questions their systems
if you played under John Wooden guess
what they're systems Bill Walton comes
in as a hippie with a beard and he says
hey I'm not shaving my beard for nobody
John Woon says you don't have to but I
don't have to play you really you
wouldn't play me I'm the number one
Prospect in the world you ain't gonna
play you can keep your beard hippie goes
back to practice with everybody else
Bill Walton gets on the bike goes cuts
his hair his beard comes back to
practice he starts playing what did John
wouldn't do to Bill
he gave him high expectation high
standards Bill Belichick High
expectation high standards military High
expectation high standards Jack Welch
High expectation high standards fire the
bottom thirty percent your employees
every year Elon Musk you don't want to
be at Twitter 50 fired 37.50 go home you
still don't want to be at Twitter the
other 1250 quid as well now we got about
2200 employees at the at the test at
Twitter almost anywhere you go
where you see a person coming out with
the level of discipline that others
don't have there was a person there with
high standard High expectation Kobe
Bryant
when did LeBron become the Beast that he
is most people are like well LeBron
James
LeBron went to the Olympics and they
recruited Kobe to go to the Olympics go
study Lebron after he went to the
Olympics with Kobe because he noticed
Kobe was a maniacal about his training
nobody ever had the standards of Kobe
including Michael Michael had better
god-given ability but Michael wanted to
party and do all the other stuff Kobe
was a maniacal everybody who ever played
with Kobe realized this guy's a monster
Alan Iverson one of my favorite players
to watch he tells a story one time he
says hey one time I'm playing against
the Lakers
let's go to dinner we go to dinner and
then Coach like what are you doing now
so I'm gonna go to the club you want to
roses now I'll take you he goes drops
him off at the club Kobe does he says
where are you going he said I got to go
back to the gym to practice
Kobe's got five championships hey guys
got zero okay so yes a person like you
can go out there and do what they're
doing but structure increases the
chances but I'm going to say this final
thing now turn it back over to use the
following don't assume our house
everything is structured
everything is not structured
don't think it's a setup where hey you
better do this you better do that you
better do this you better do that
they're free to do a lot of things it's
a system that you have on how you score
points YouTube doesn't tell you what to
do YouTube will tell if you create good
content good SEO good lighting good
camera good this good audio
and you keep doing it consistently we're
going to reward you our family is the
same way we're the ultimate capitalism
family you do this you earn this you do
this you earn that you don't you don't
that's capitalism you don't have to do
it you don't have to watch the
documentary you don't have to read the
book but you also don't have to play
iPad so there is that element of
capitalism in the house where you got to
earn or else you don't get I'm curious
what books do you recommend that every
parent have their child read some of the
books I have my kids have read you know
my oldest has probably read 500 who HQ
books I was interested in buying who HQ
the brand which is owned by penguin they
won't sell it but I
I I watched some of the stuff they add
in who HQ which is politically motivated
and there's other competitors to who HQ
I was going to buy another book brand uh
that was out there I will tell you I
like my kids to study individuals so
studying individuals they got to study
the founding fathers they got to study
why America is the greatest country in
the world they got to study the musks of
the world the Teslas of the world the
Franklins of the world the
um Lincolns of the world I want them to
study great leaders on what happened
there okay with them great presidents I
want them to study John F Kennedy Reagan
go study those guys I'll tell you what
happened the other day there's a frame
in my office I don't know if you guys
went into my office there's a book
that's on the wall and they send me the
book
and it's about a guy named Thomas Seoul
I don't know if you know who Thomas soul
is Thomas Sol is uh probably one of the
smartest men we have in America today
he's 91 years old uh 91 92 93 years old
came up with Milton Friedman I don't
know if you guys know Milton Friedman is
Milton Friedman is the maybe the
greatest Economist we've ever had
outside of Adam Smith and all these
other guys Milton Friedman was if you
want to really get into the space go
watch Milton Friedman with Phil Donahue
it's 43 minutes and just watch that for
yourself and you'll be fast I think he's
wearing a yellow coat or a yellow shirt
incredible if you go there and then you
watch Thomas Soul debate just type in
Thomas sold debate it's an older Thomas
sold with glasses he's debating a lady
you're going to the rabbit hole and
watching this stuff forever my kid
book comes in he reads the Thomas Soul
book okay
I come home he says Daddy what are we
doing I said what do you mean what are
we doing I have to go make money so you
have to go make money yeah I gotta go
make money I don't know how I'm gonna go
make money I'm gonna go and knock on the
doors here in the people in the
neighborhood and I'm gonna see how I can
make money with them so what are you
talking about he says no I got to go as
a capitalist I gotta go make money but I
can't take credit from I've never told
him to go out there and find a way to
make your own money you read this book
so he goes out comes back nothing
happens sweating it's 100 degrees
outside next day his brother joins him
and his sister joins him so it's him 11
9 7 they're out
and an hour later somebody calls us hey
are these your kids yes they're out here
knocking on doors saying they want to
find a way to make money do you mind if
I teach them how to walk my dog because
I need somebody to walk my dogs I said
no problem It's a 65 year old lady so
they walk the dogs
they come back sweat
totally sweaty messed up
and they come back and they say
um
yeah Daddy this lady gave us twenty
dollars I said she gave me twenty
dollars yeah I told him whatever you
make I'm gonna match it so if you make
20 you get 40. I said so what do we want
to do with this twenty dollars I said
who's the CEO of the company he said
well that's me my oldest I said so what
what amount of this 40 you want to pay
yourself he says I'm gonna pay myself
you know 20 or whatever okay I said what
amount you want to pay the second best
employee he says no Dylan worked really
hard I'm going to pay him 15 or whatever
the number and Senator came and she was
Supporting Cast and she was sweet so
we're gonna give her five dollars so
she's all happy we're doing a video by
the way it's a great video I take the
twenty dollars the first one and I frame
it in my office I take a picture of them
walking the dogs into my office and I
put the book the first book that they
read that caused them influenced them to
become capitalists so for me it's less
about what
brand book they read it's who they read
if your kid reads Thomas Soul oh my God
if your kid reads innovators creators
founding fathers of America what these
guys went through to create the greatest
country in the world that's going to
inspire them in weird ways these guys
have written more books than I read the
amount of books my oldest son has read I
did not read until I was 28 years old
this guy's read at 11 years old imagine
the imagination with this kid on how you
know how he's wired so I think it's more
names and individuals than it is like
certain brands how do you know someone
is ready to have kids yeah it's a good
question so to me I think the wrong
people are having too many kids and the
right people are not having enough kids
I think the the wrong people are
Reckless when it comes kids they don't
think about it a lot they're like hey
government's going to pay me money or
hey you want to have unprotected said oh
I'm pregnant oh
versus the right people who overthink it
guys like you it's like well you know if
we have a kid it's going to cost us
around 280 000 between 0 to 18 and if we
want to have three that's about a
million dollars and if we're going to
put them in our private school for us
it's probably not going to be 280 it's
probably more like 600 000 so babe if
we're going to have this at 12 interest
on this fund with American Funds
Investment Company act you're
overthinking it right where a guy like
you know how many kids you need to have
do you know how many kids you need to
have you need to have five kids I was
about to say one or two no no no see a
guy like you yeah I want to see a guy
like you have five kids because I know
you're gonna if they're gonna be like
you we need more use in the world but if
you have one kid you're screwing up the
ratios think about what I'm saying to
you the rate of the people who have
money who are resources you're gentle
just looking at your energy you're an
incredible father for a girl your girl's
gonna love you she's gonna be all over
you you're going to be like her hero for
the rest of her life right
but one kid two kids oh man we gotta go
back to having four five my wife and I
and if we were
I I I'd have 20 kids my wife would be
pregnant every year and she'd have a
three month vacation every year of not
being pregnant and then you you got your
vacation babe you're done boom next one
here next one here we'd be going 20 20
years straight but no I think the right
people need to have more kids and
they're overthinking having kids and the
wrong people are under thinking having
kids so if we can get those ratios down
properly then uh Society will be in a
better place so on the the topic of the
ESG ratings I know that you said that
when you sold your company you had a
really high rating now did you do that
methodically what was your rating at the
end what is a typically good rating and
did you try to raise your rating before
you sold the company we should explain
what that is if you wouldn't mind going
into that yeah so the ESG they score
your company on environmental social
governance so how much are you helping
out with the environment social like how
many women do you have on your board how
many gays do you have on your board how
many people from colored people all this
stuff that's the hey do you want that
score to be there and then how much back
are you given to environment just to
tell you how pathetic this ESG score is
is that a government agency no not at
all no private it's a private agency
funded by some interesting people
there's an organization out there called
open Society Foundation started by Soros
whom he gave 32 billion dollars to by
the way 32 billion dollars you can
Google this to see how much money he's
given to open Society Foundation since I
think 1994 the number is 32 billion
dollars so ESG you get the score here's
how pathetic yes she is
the score which company do you think has
done more for the environment in America
Philip Morris or Tesla probably probably
Tesla okay Tesla has a much lower ESG
score than Philip Morris Philip Morris
has a plus rating what a great
environmental social governance company
out there Philip Morris great job guys
no it's because Elon Musk thinks the
snesg stands for satanic and he doesn't
want to abide to the scoring system that
these Soros and Finks and some of these
guys in the world are doing that Larry
Fink is like I feel ashamed I think the
word ESG is being weaponized you do not
feel ashamed you know exactly what
you're doing you're running a company
with 10 trillion dollars of assets under
management you're crushing the EFT game
you're of course you're you're the one
that's managing other people's money but
at the same time you're influencing
where that money goes to you know it's
not like you're they're doing it you
tell them where the money is going into
yes you need some approval but you get
to do the influence so for me the ESG
side that's a little bit
concerning is they are the largest
shareholder themselves Like Larry finkus
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard
these three companies are the largest
shareholders
of 88 of s p 500 companies let me say
that one more time you got 500 companies
S P 500
88 of those companies their largest
shareholder of those companies is either
State Street Vanguard or BlackRock okay
so whose phone call do you think you
have to pick up when they call you
BlackRock State Street and Vanguard who
do you fear if you're to see all those
companies State Street Vanguard
BlackRock you better answer those calls
who are you going to hire
you're gonna have to hire
whoever they're going to want should
hire because you want the high score so
now let's go to other Industries
Department of Defense Raytheon General
Dynamics boink Northrop Grumman
three out of the four top shareholders
in almost every one of those companies
guess which companies they are State
Street Vanguard BlackRock so the
commander-in-chief
is not who we think it is
it's the CEO of BlackRock Vanguard State
Street it's people like Larry Fink and
George Soros they have influence we've
always been like oh my god look how rich
is it is it good for a guy like Elon
Musk to be as rich as he is
Elon Musk is nothing compared to what
these guys are doing collectively
together they have got I don't know how
many people that have signed off to the
numbers here I think it's 60 something
like that or 51 people that have signed
off to this would be part of the CSG
Community they have access to 66
trillion dollars of assets under
management you know how much total money
there is in the world circulating you
know the total money it's around 430
trillion dollars 440 trillion dollars
they they control 66 trillion dollars
of the entire world's wealth when I say
control I mean if influencing is what
they can do so when you're seeing some
of these companies making the kind of
decisions that they're making you're
asking yourself why would they do such a
thing that is so stupid you know right
now if you wanted to go be nominated for
an Oscars I don't know if you guys know
the data with the nominating for Oscars
what percentage of your employees need
to be part of a lgbtq community
what percentage of your employees actors
editors Cutters the percentage needs to
be from Native Americans disability LGBT
black if you don't you cannot be
nominated which means
almost every single movie in the history
of oscars that won an Oscar would have
never won with today's guidelines that's
how pathetic this is getting right now
with the direction they're going to
influence what you're going to be doing
with whatever company or project you're
running now you haven't said this
explicitly but I can kind of read
between the lines if your theory on all
of this turns out to be true is this
stuff that you're nervous to be saying
online no I'm not nervous to be saying
online we know what happened to other
people that potentially had knowledge
all I'm saying to you is the follow-up
everything I'm saying to you
you need to go to your own due diligence
type in 88 S P 500 BlackRock Vanguard
State Street are you okay with that
that's what you got to ask yourself for
example
there's not a single other phone I want
in an iPhone
I've had an iPhone since 2008 okay I've
had an iPhone since 2008. I love an
iPhone I love the iPhone okay if I look
at what a Droid looks like in an iPhone
and I use a Droid I'm always going to
come back to an iPhone okay
if your Droid what's the annoying thing
about an iPhone person texting a Droid
person green green when you're on a
flight I can't talk to you or if I'm
creating a group text and you're a Droid
person you screw the whole thing up do
you know I often think about not adding
the Droid person in the group text I'm
sending because you're annoying me I
can't communicate with you so watch this
there are now 58 of market share is this
the Monopoly law in America is 50
percent
we don't have another phone company
that's competing with these guys I was a
die-hard Nextel person I love the next
step the Nextel Blackberry that they had
was phenomenal you know the old next
though you guys are too young to
remember but there was an EXO Blackberry
we need somebody to want to compete with
this we need others to want to compete
with this so if it doesn't concern you
don't do it but if you have three
companies that have influence in 50
different industries that ought to be
something we should be concerned about
okay because they're going to be around
for a while the president's going to
come in one term two term eight years
there's not a lot they can be doing but
these guys are going to be around for
decades but for your own personal safety
you're not nervous about saying any of
these things intentionally I'm not I'm
not uh not for my personal safety at all
who do you think is the most powerful
man on the planet some of those names I
gave I don't think it's the president I
think president is one of them I think
the people that run any of the virtual
governments they're for sure one of the
most powerful men on the planet uh
Facebook Zuck is on that list you know
Elon is now on that list
uh I think the Google guys are more
low-key but they're also on that list on
what influence they have Bezos is on
that list with the control that he has
but it's the Finks it's the Sorrows his
son Alex that's going to take over
and then next comes some of these guys
that are the media Moguls you know
Rupert Murdoch is still on that list it
used to be Ted Turner but Ted Turner is
not running CNN anymore when they sold
time when they screwed him over he
should have kept running that
organization that man would have been
the most powerful man in America if not
a top five power powerful man in America
but uh yeah these are some of the names
you have to be really really careful
with and by the way think about how most
people learn
what do you think most people learn
about Oppenheimer how do you think most
people for the first time ever learned
about Oppenheimer you think they read a
book on it you think they went and
studied Oppenheimer you think pre the
movie coming out if you ask the average
person who's Oppenheimer they're like
man is that a beer from Germany what is
this is no no it's not a beer it's a guy
that it's the nuclear bomb and Einstein
no way yeah most people learn about
Oppenheimer through what a movie right
most people learn about Howard Hughes
through what movie most people learn
about you know a lot of these stories of
people through movies so you gotta also
put a lot of influence of these people
that are making the movies and how
they're feeding the messaging and
persuading the younger generation that's
too lazy to go read their own books
because they're too much on Tick Tock
and Instagram so universities for people
after they're done with high school and
college it's movies so media's got a lot
of influence uh those whoever's telling
the story has got a lot of influence
over people so you gotta also give some
kind of power to the people that are
telling the stories couldn't that also
be social media and what they decide to
push and how their algorithms rank
virtual governments is what I said you
know the social virtual government to me
is Zuck Facebook you know Twitter all
those guys they control the algorithms
you know RFK just sued Google yesterday
and YouTube for censor again so Kennedy
right now who's running for office he's
saying he's being silenced they're
taking his interviews down
etc etc so no question about it they're
also some of the most powerful people
kind of a random question but do you
think that you need to be a U.S born
citizen to run for president see I
actually don't know if I agree with that
entirely because I think if we're trying
if we're basing it off of Merit and what
you can do for this country limiting the
pool of people
from people like Elon Musk from people
like you I don't think it's a productive
thing if you ask me to question and
somebody says you know for example I
went to a restaurant in Beverly Hills
it's called Crustaceans my favorite
restaurant in in Beverly Hills that I
would go to Crustaceans has two kitchens
okay one of the kitchens you have to be
part of the on family to go in that
kitchen okay so they could hire you and
there's that secret kitchen you cannot
get into because they make this garlic
noodles that you think they spiced it
with every single addictive drug in the
world because when you eat these noodles
oh my God it's unbelievable
you've got to go you gotta go there okay
and now they have these cigar uh thing
that they make that you eat with smoke
comes out and they got these crab legs
that they make and anyways when you go
there you'll walk in and say what was
this all about insane beautiful food I
respect a brand that says the recipe
that's been passed on by generation
is only if you're an aunt you can't come
in here and steal our recipe and go do
it elsewhere I salute it I respect it
everybody else that works here you go in
the other kitchen is it a form of
discrimination a hundred percent you are
discriminating
so America can say Hey you can only come
in the kitchen here
and make decisions for America at the
highest level president if you're part
of the on family if you're not we
discriminate against other people that
are born here it is an element of
discrimination that is a discriminatory
policy that they have in place but I
fully understand it now if they wanted
to kind of amend it or change it and you
know you've been here for 35 years and
you know now you can run you know you
you've had to serve you've had to you
know pay on a certain amount of taxes if
you have to create jobs or you certain
ways you had to go get the degrees from
this this that or certain ways to get in
there that you've contributed to society
you've been a net positive to society to
America in ways others haven't been then
maybe you get the car to be able to run
but
the concern for me is the following
there are people who love America way
more immigrants who love America way
more than those who are born here you
know a person who lost a father young
who sits with their best friend who's
bitching about his father because he
discipline him too much
the friend says can you please stop
bitching about your dad that's
challenging you who's alive I wish my
dad was alive to discipline me stop
complaining oh my God you're such a
crybaby I'm sick of your of
complaining about your dad right and
then that kid walks up and saying man
I'm so glad my dad is alive what a
perspective right there's an element to
it there's too many Americans that are
bitching about their dad that's alive
where other countries wish
your founding fathers cared about their
country as much as they did they wish
they wish and these Americans are sinner
well I think I'm entitled to this I
think I'm entitled to this I'm entitled
to this you're a Founder you've ran a
company before you know what it is when
you work your ass off for that money and
you make that money and as a Founder
what do you do if I'm going to buy 20
cases of this water for my office and
they're going to say well it's uh 628 uh
you know what here 628 but if it's you
spending that money you're gonna be like
wait a minute what does Costco sell it
for 542 let's buy from Costco you'll go
save that 80 as a Founder but one of
your employees going to be like just pay
the 628 who cares right the founders
mentality wants to save the 80 you know
what America is today America is today
filled with a bunch of spoiled brands
who are spending daddy's money that they
never made
how much debt do we have right now is it
32 yeah 32 trillion dollars why do we
have 32 trillion dollars because the
kids
the grandkids the great great grandkids
are using Daddy's Money
not caring at all who worked their asses
off prior to them to make this money
make it the number one country in the
world so you have some good habits but
no yeah pay those guys this much ah send
70 billion to Ukraine even though
Russia's annual budget is 65 billion
dollars who cares send it to them yeah
send this thing over here I think uh a
little bit of people from
America would be very interesting if
Elon Musk was a president you know
what's interesting is that Jack
mentioned earlier how wealth is usually
squandered in three generations and
couldn't we say now that like Jack and I
are almost that third generation of
America and we're somewhat squandering
it
in a sense that's what you're that's a
good point yeah that's exactly the point
so for me I think if if uh you know one
would wonder like yesterday if Yvette is
speaking your first generation and
you're hearing him sell America in a way
that most Americans can't sell America
you know what's my simplest question I
want to ask a candidate sell me America
can you sell America
sell America like if I ask you right now
sell me why somebody
ought to create content on YouTube you
could sell it if I said sell me on the
idea of making money at a young age sell
me real estate sell me why I ought to be
in a different industry most of these
candidates don't even know how to sell
America
they don't know how to sell America how
do you sell America sometimes to sell
America property you have to know what
is the opposite of America and the only
way you know what the opposite of
America is you have to have lived in
another place you have to have
experience what it's like to give a
perspective some somebody's not paying
attention to it so is it a lot that I
think they'll eventually amend I think
they'll eventually amend it do I think
it's going to happen next 5 10 20 48
years I don't know where do you think
America went wrong because it seems like
for the most part people are spending
more time on drama uh Stupid arguments
Petty things where do you think that
began uh because it seems like from my
perspective that there are much bigger
issues at hand the people just don't
care about yeah they just ignore so let
me ask you this so so let's just say you
got two kids
and your kids are going to come and hang
out with my kids at my house they're
seven eight years old okay
um what's the first question you're
going to ask from your wife
about where your kids are going I'm not
sure what would you do you want to know
who your kids friend's parents are
yes okay what do you want to know about
them what do they do for work okay what
else where do they live okay
um maybe
what what they're teaching their kids
okay so let me let me give you which one
of them gives you a red flag okay
um yeah babe it's a good family the
mother is a teacher at a Christian
private school in the community and the
dad is a real estate guy
whose father was a senior pastor at XYZ
that's one family let me give you the
next one yeah it's the the they're
raised by their father it's an
interesting it's a single father that's
raising the kids and uh yeah you know so
I think he runs the nightclub one of the
biggest nightclubs in Miami is what he
runs yeah so that's what he does okay
I'll give you another situation yeah uh
you know uh the the the mother one of
the girls told me that the mother you
know sometimes smokes weed you know uh
in the backyard and they've smelled weed
in a house before but I don't know
apparently she's sweet which one of
those three families do you say I'm a
little bit concerned about the kids
being there without me being there and
which one of them are you like okay cool
let them be there probably the weed one
I'd be concerned about okay uh first one
I'd feel more comfortable okay why
though I feel like they're probably more
structured more disciplined
um and would teach values that I think
would be conducive to raising someone
who's wonderful and I agree okay so
watch this but you're playing odds yes
are you converting to believe in Jesus
because those guys are you know no but
you're playing odds to see which one
you're going to feel your kids being
safer is it 100 no well you're playing
the odds game right okay we went wrong
the day we took God out of school it's
just period we went wrong kids standing
up praying I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation but under God you know invisible
we went wrong when that was gone we went
wrong when it's like hey let's wake up
heavenly father thank you for this thank
you for this please give us the you know
thank you for the nourishment and today
allow me to stay focused to study and
learn and get better with the teachers
okay there was nothing wrong with that
with us praying Woodrow Wilson kind of
messed it up a little bit
but taking God out of school was a big
mess
not because the fear was well I don't
want my kid to be a Jesus loving person
that's not it there is a the fear of God
plays a very big role one of the reasons
why I didn't do uh uh you know as a kid
I did a lot of stupid things and I you
know wasn't a kid that you know you
would have wanted your kids to be around
but if there's one thing that worked
even though I didn't believe in God I
was afraid of God because my mother
would say the one line Hey listen you
can lie to me you can get away with me
not finding out what you're doing but
trust me everything you do wrong God is
watching you she probably said that to
me a couple thousand times so every time
I was about to do something wrong my
mom's not gonna find out but God is
watching right the fear of God prevented
me from doing a lot of bad things a lot
of kids are the same way as well now
some people say well that's exactly why
I turned out so messed up and I have
anxiety and panic because there was the
fear of God right okay fine you can go
and complain about your parents
putting the fear of God in you but I
think it's more good than bad so if
we're playing the odds game taking God
out massive problem massive so think
about this you don't believe in God you
believe in God but you don't have a God
where it's like you don't Jesus or
Christianity or any of that stuff right
okay so if you have to choose which of
the two things to put in school and you
have to have one of them which one will
it be you ready for this technical
question would you rather have your kids
have to learn
about God
and pray every morning and to pledge
allegiance to the flag
but they don't get lgbtq learning you
know all the different Sexes and all
that stuff or would you take God out of
school and add they have to learn about
what it is to be gay lesbian bisexual
queer trans and they have to know at an
early age because it's part of us being
free and not being discriminatory what
you do is too would you want your kids
to learn about and you have to give up
the other one I feel like there has to
be a balance because you don't want to
be oppressive or let's say your your kid
is gay you don't want them to feel like
they can't be accepted and they can't be
themselves but at the same time there's
got to be some sort of you got to pick
one of them
I don't know man I I don't so that's a
problem but that's a problem yeah and
the reason why that's a problem is the
following thing
um
are you gay
me yeah no
what do I need to do listening what do I
need to do to convert into being gay I
don't think you you can you don't think
I could convert you to being gay I don't
think so okay yeah so let me ask you
this uh who converted you into getting a
real estate license I did who influenced
you though
how did you learn about real estate I
saw a TV commercial for a Million Dollar
Listing perfect I got in my mind and you
were influenced to be a realtor
you weren't born with wanting to be a
realtor Bingo yeah did you get it
let me explain to you what I mean by
this sure please show stats came out
that shows which generation
is the gayest generation of all
that's part of the lgbtq community do
you think you care more about what I
think at this age or when you were 14
years old definitely 14. no problem me
too right so
do you think it's easier to convert you
in a way of thinking at 14 or 33 14. of
course right okay I became a Christian
because somebody talked to me about it I
got into Insurance because somebody
influenced me to get into Insurance okay
I got into bodybuilding because I was
influenced by Arnold Schwarz I went to
Santa Monica Community College because I
was influenced because that's where
Arnold went in from somebody influenced
you right four generations five
generations traditionalist you got the
Boomers Millennials Gen X and you got
gen Z you ready
traditionalist point eight percent of
our gate point eight percent of
traditionalists are gay Boomers 2.6
percent
then you go to five percent then you go
to ten percent you know what percentage
of gen Z identifies as lgbtq 21 percent
21 so who do you think cares less about
what you and I think traditionalists or
gen Z's traditionalists you think if you
and I are 70 years old and we're gay do
you really think you and I care about
what other people think what do you
think no you're coming out you ever seen
a grandma or grandfather drop f-bombs
and it's like get your butter out of my
because that you understand I'm 10 years
away from living and dying like I don't
give a what you think about me but
if 21 of gen Z is gay they're being
influence just like you were influenced
to be a realtor just like I was
influenced to go into SMC influence
that's a problem so the fact that you
a very smart guy a super successful guy
at your age cannot tell the two apart
that means you're you're not really
putting a lot of thought into what's
going to influence who because God faith
that's going to influence you to do what
completely different thing don't you
think that some of that though is a bit
of that overall people are on somewhere
on a spectrum and if you're let's say a
two out of ten or a three out of 10 that
maybe you're more open about that
whereas in other Generations you weren't
and perhaps it's somewhere in the middle
no I think lgbtq is a religion and you
choose which religion you want to be in
front of your kids okay uh you choose if
a person is gay you're eventually going
to be gay
you're gonna be gay you're not gonna be
if you're gonna do what you're going to
do like for example I I thought about I
interviewed a guy who was a um
uh negotiator FBI agent who would sit
down with people that killed
um uh uh that were you know murderers
that killed their own family members and
I said so what gets somebody to get to
the point of wanting to do something
like this
and he explained how there's a
difference between what you're born with
what's your influence with and then to
take the action right there are some
people that are born who are dark human
beings period that they enjoy it they're
born that way you know if you look at
the Iceman I don't know if you've ever
seen interviews of the Iceman have you
ever watched any movies of Iceman yeah
that guy is cold and he enjoyed what he
did what percentage of the world is like
that what would you say point one
percent okay so are we going to say no
he was influenced to be that way there
had to be a darker person in his life to
get him to be that dark no he's born
that way okay are some people born gay
maybe maybe okay but if we take a
thousand gay people what percentage of
them are gay because they were born gay
what percentage of our gay because they
were influenced to be gay or life
influenced them to be gay that's a real
question we have to talk about I
understand it's very uncomfortable I
think it would be just attraction or
like like I am attracted to certain
people and a certain type I'm not
attracted to another type no problem so
I feel like that would be the same thing
with gender I'm like if you're attracted
to men or women that would be Graham
yeah do you think you need to learn how
to give a to another boy 11
years old no that book is in schools
recommended teaching by many teachers in
America do you think that's a problem
sure do you think it's a better usage of
my time to learn how money Works yes or
how to please another boy at 11 years
old right so then you have to decide
your values and principles between the
two
I think these values being taught to
kids are kids typically more liberal or
conservative liberal liberal are you
kidding me I'm all liberal like let's
try drugs let's try this let's break the
law let's break this hey let's sneak
into the swimming pool have the cops
chase us hey let's test this out we're
liberal right so we don't need to teach
more liberal policies to kids they're
gonna do we're gonna do stuff we
need to balance it out with what with
this okay so now watch this do you think
Rich greedy people who have a lot of
money do you think they need to be
taught more conservative stuff or more
this stuff
liberal stuff what do you think do you
see how this is working out so to me
it's the other way around I think we've
mixed it up so
be understood this guy's 28 years old
he's gay no problem I got plenty of gay
employees I have plenty of lesbian
leaders in my company plenty of them and
see how my relationship is with them you
chose to do that as an adult salute a
couple that were here yesterday just
watch how they hugged me when they see
me we love each other we have an
incredible relationship then later on we
need to learn and say hey man can you be
a little bit kind to these people dude
relax
they just see things in different way
than you do all good I think we need to
give conservative values to kids when
we're liberals and I think we need to
inject a little bit of this when we're
older successful to be a little bit more
understanding I think the education is
out of whack
you know maybe the lgbtq stuff can be
taught to people that are older to be a
little bit more gentle to them but it's
outside you're asking a question I'm
gonna go back to God is one of them
what's being taught in school is one of
them not enough money Finance is one of
them the way we turn our heroes into
here you know who the hero-making
machine is in America is a problem today
we recognize complainers
today we recognize who posts more naked
pictures on social media gets the most
likes today we recognize that more than
somebody like you is responsible makes
his own money works his tail off you're
you seem very kind you seem humble you
seem likable yet you're doing your
research yet you're willing to talk to
people
so we've confused kids on who the hero
today is oh my God poor person look at
this person they came out of the closet
at 14 years old let's do 28 articles on
them but that 14 year old kid who made
28 000 independently that's whatever
it's not a big deal but let's highlight
this person what are you doing which one
do we need more for society more people
coming out of closet or more 14 year
olds that are making twenty eight
thousand dollars on their own we're
turning the wrong people into Heroes and
it's confusing the F out of kids so to
me those are things that we've been
doing that's kind of messed up America
how do you decide who is welcome on your
podcast versus who isn't you've had a
lot of controversial people I saw
recently had Anthony Weiner on who had
sent uh sexually explicit photos to a
minor if I'm not mistaken how do you
decide what is crossing the line versus
what is it I have to be interested in
the story of the individual if I'm not
interested I'm not interested so for
example if you talk to Sam and you ask
how many people have given us offered a
hundred two hundred thousand dollars to
be on the podcast we would never do it
okay you're not going to give us money
to be on the podcast because I know I'm
lying to the audience and I'm gonna be
fake because I don't care about your
story I have to be interested in you if
I'm doing it because
I'm doing a favor or you paid me money
I'm forgetting who the priority is you
have to make sure you're you're honest
and straight up with your audience so
Alex Jones and then jenk those two guys
hate each other when I asked Jake would
you ever do a podcast with Alex Jones oh
my God absolutely not no no this Anthony
Weiner then I'm bringing a Catholic
priest
okay Kris Cuomo then I'm bringing you
know Jordan Peterson so to me I've
interviewed Samuel gravano he killed 19
people you kidding me like what's he
doing there I mean what are you
interviewing him for right I want to
know motives I want to know why I want
to know why you think the way you do I
want to know what influences you to
think you're that right about your
philosophies and ideas what got you to
the Tipping Point of make the decisions
that you made but my best guess are the
people that I'm interested in their
stories and I like misunderstood people
I like complicated people
um
yeah I'm typically interested in
complicated and misunderstood people and
Anthony Weiner different story
when he came in we were having a podcast
prepping a bag and I said look guys uh
he was pitched to me by my uh producer
and he had a book coming out I said yeah
I'd love to talk to this guy for one
reason not because if I'm interested in
him I want to know
your wife was Hillary Clinton's
right-hand person this is a person that
knows everything about Hillary Clinton
good about ugly and that's a very
complicated individual Hillary and Bill
I want to know about these guys so for
me I want because I'd like to interview
Bill and Hillary Clinton and publicly I
tweeted out and I said I'd like to
publicly extend an invitation for Bill
and Hillary Clinton to be on the podcast
you know over the years your legacy
you're known as the most powerful couple
in the history of politics in the last
50 years
and there's a lot of rumors about you
and there's a lot of things said about
you whether true or wrong I want to
discuss it if you're open to it let me
know and boom we got a bunch of
commentary Pat's not suicidal Pat's not
dispatch not that I want to talk to the
clintons I want to talk to Putin I want
to talk to some complicated people in
the world I want to have these
conversations with Maduro I want to sit
down and talk to some of the folks from
Iran uh because it's complicated but
we're sitting in the back about Anthony
Weiner and I said look if he's
respectful we'll have a respectful
discourse but if he's disrespectful and
he wants to you know come in and pig and
wrestle and all that's I have no problem
wrestling with a pig for two hours I'm
all game you know we'll have a good time
and obviously I don't know if you've
seen it or not it was a very intense
conversation from beginning to the end
because he came in disrespectful and
then let's play Let's play ball and it
was a blast we had a good time together
for two hours I love that philosophy and
I wish I could expand on that more but I
I appreciate the fact that it's just
about satisfying your own curiosity oh
yeah who would you like to talk to and
there's certain people I would love to
talk to you know Martin shkreli for
example but I know he's very
controversial and bringing him on some
people could say oh you're platforming
somebody with this ideology he's like no
I want to see very interesting I know
that's he'd be very interesting yeah but
I am concerned I would watch it if you
guys did it okay we're gonna we're gonna
try for it
but I think he could be a very
misunderstood person but having him on
and are you kidding me you know what
things he can teach about big Pharma
yeah you know what things he can teach
about how if he was able to charge it
for five thousand dollars or whatever he
was doing what can you leak about what
about the patent laws there's so many
different good questions to ask us where
do you draw the line in terms of your
guest is there a guest you would not
choose to have on I'm trying to think
who I wouldn't like give me an idea of
who give me a name white supremacist for
example oh and I'm not interested in
that you know a full-blown like a KKK
the Hat on all of that I'm not
interested in that I'm not interested in
that
um who else ask me who guys I've had a
lot of people that people would say you
should never have that person on every
time I have a guest politically the
other half is upset with me every time
well I can't believe you had them on I
can't believe you had them on but now
we've had so many people from left and
right on that they're both eventually
they're immunized they're like listen
this guy's gonna have them on we can't
tell them what to do like a cartel
leader I would have them on absolutely
really absolutely I would interview uh I
would absolutely interview cartel are
you kidding me you know the types of
people I interviewed in the mob and
cartels those are some of my favorite
videos yes by the way and and I love
those interviews uh first time I called
Sammy the bull I'm like Sammy
uh who the is this this is Patrick
are you the guy that did that interview
with Michael Francis and you put the
title mafia boss you know he was never
on Mafia Boss he was a couple what the
you doing if you're gonna do I'm
the only person that interviews me as a
professional like Diane Sawyer three
hours later me just listening to him I
said Sammy
can we just meet face to face let's have
a meeting if you're comfortable then
let's do an interview let me think about
it nine months later I'm in Phoenix
we go to this building I'm walking all
the way in the back I want to like a
warehouse type of place and we sit there
for three hours
and you just talk and talk and talk and
talking talking
he said okay I think I'm ready let's do
the interview then we did the interview
and now boom 20 million views I don't
know I think it's a 19 and a half 20
million views today but yeah I'll
definitely interview cartel leaders I
wanted to get your reaction to this clip
before we end this is a bit more of a
current event that we're going to be
posting sure this is a clip from Mia
Khalifa and she said that if you marry
the wrong person early there should be
no shame in getting divorced if you're
with the wrong person get divorced and
this clip is going viral and it's this
if you haven't seen it I have not seen
it married at 18 divorced at 21 second
marriage married at 25 divorced at 28.
third engagement engaged at 29 ended it
at 30 but I kept the ring I'm still
keeping Tom Brady on his toes
we should not be afraid to leave these
men we are not stuck with these people
marriage is not a sanctimonious thing it
is it is paperwork it's something it's
it's it's a commitment you make to
someone but if you feel like
you're not getting anything from that
commitment and you're trying you gotta
go you gotta go you have to go I know
it's difficult to fill out paperwork and
to make appointments and to do all of
these things but this is your life do
you want to be stuck with someone
period do you want to be stuck with
something is this girl
okay yeah it depends on what she's
saying here on a couple different things
one
one of the most important books I read
on relationship was 101 questions to ask
before you get engaged I read this book
and the woman I thought I wanted to
marry I was like no that's not what
you're looking for you you want this
like wow out of 101 questions like 54 of
them were important to me
so then I was talking to four girls at
that time I gave them all the books and
I said I need you to read this book and
let's have a meeting together go through
the answers I knew three of them wasn't
going to work out my wife and I had a
six hour meeting with that book
and then I'm like okay cool let's date
for a year and a half then I'm gonna
marry this girl we date for a year and a
half we have a bunch of fights you know
and then eventually I'm like nope I'm
gonna marry this group but I knew after
I read the book this could be somebody I
can invest my time into
but most people don't marry based on
values and principles most people marry
based on nice breasts based on a
beautiful butt based on a beautiful face
based on an incredible chemistry in the
bedroom sex was great you went to a
nightclub you dance good together you
have a blast together you laugh together
all of that stuff aren't the reasons to
marry okay those are great reasons to
date I dated two girls
whom
one of them I knew from the beginning I
was never going to marry this girl and
by the way I love this girl we had an
incredible time together but I knew we
were never going to marry each other
that we have fun unbelievable fun did we
do crazy things together out of control
was it a blast yes yes was that going to
marry her no was she going to marry me
no eventually we sat down and we said
look this is not working out and I want
to get married and I I don't think we're
going to be together I said I'm not
going to date anybody until you date
somebody first because I want to be
respectful to you boom she goes date
somebody first I said now you're a
dating boom now I got no and I started
dating another girl I was dating
eventually one day after being together
for two and a half years we had the
awkward moment
uh sex is amazing we're having a lot of
fun uh we're like two kids every you
would see us you know you'd see us at
Venice Beach she's on top of me you were
just wrestling we're having a blast
we're laughing of course we're having a
fight and some couple unfortunate events
happened that you know took away life
out of the relationship and we lost a
lot of momentum but it got to a point
one day by the way I'm an atheist at the
same when I'm dating this girl one day
I'm like I want to know if we're
together because we actually have
substance and things to talk about or if
it's sexual and fun I said look I want
us to go a month without sex and she
says what see I want us to go a month
without sex
are you joking no I'm serious with you
you're joking there's no way you can do
this I don't know if I can do this I'm
saying let's try to see if we can do it
to see what we do late at night great
first time we go out hey
um movie's done at an expedition you
wanna
ah I'm gonna drop you off now you got to
realize my pants they're about to blow
up I mean I'm like ready to do something
with her I'm like babe we got to spend
some time I'm freaking on fire with
testosterone I'm a high testosterone
type of guy and I'm dropping her off and
I'm just cursing myself out you're more
the hell is wrong with your man you
should have done this next night same
thing
next night same thing
two three weeks later we don't have
anything to talk about
I'm like
great relationship I don't know if we
can be married should I say let's go to
church together
see if we can figure something out here
are you being religious no I'm just
trying to figure out if I want to get
married you want to get married to me no
yeah I want to get married to you I got
a ring but I don't know if we can make
it work I don't know what marriage is
all about we need something to have a
basis
and we go to church one time so
uncomfortable for her I'm like I'm not
going to make you do this and then
eventually we broke up she's happily
married she's got beautiful kids we're
still in contact I'm very happy for her
and the other one is also happily
married got kids all that stuff why is
this person getting all these eyeballs
she's saying some opinion that people
want to hear apparently is that you can
break a marriage in her space What is
marriage in her space
there is no meaning in marriage in her
world why should even anybody react to
that video you're talking about a porn
star who goes around and marriage after
marriage after marriage in that world
what is the basis what is the standards
I think the worry is that she is
teaching people that getting married is
not that big of a deal and if it doesn't
work out just divorce oh so you don't
like that what do you think about that I
think in a sense well my parents are
divorced I think if the marriage is not
working I think it takes two people to
equally want that marriage to succeed
and I feel like if one person doesn't or
if one person has checked out one person
gets addicted to drugs and there's
nothing that could be done I think there
are circumstance or cheating I think
there are certain circumstances where
divorce I think is the right choice for
people to separate so do you think uh
she is potentially influencing others to
leave their husbands do you think she's
potentially doing that yes I do you do
to a certain degree got it and do you
think that bad to influence I think if
someone's influenced by that they
probably shouldn't be together to begin
with so but I think do you think she's
also influencing some other girls to
maybe not be doing the stuff that
they're doing and now they're leaving
their husbands and be Reckless who cares
if marriage doesn't work out go have
your fun live your life it's about you
do you think she's influencing some
young girls to ruin their lives yes
possibly possibly Graham you're a smart
guy it ain't possible she is she's a
diplomat okay he is a diplomat but he's
he's kind of uh getting in his own way
instead of just being straight up with
it you know you're right
it goes back to my point okay where the
wrong people are becoming Heroes
and they're influencing and converting
and baptizing younger generation to live
dumb lives that's the problem we are
turning the wrong people into Heroes so
if that person has that kind of
influence do you want even more of that
influence in schools in high schools in
junior high schools no you're validating
my point from earlier on
on why the content we're teaching in our
schools is ruining our younger
generation by confusing the hell out of
them and that girl right there is a hero
today to many people because she's
getting the eyeballs she's not now what
would happen if she all of a sudden came
out and she says I've lived a terrible
life I've made a lot of dumb decisions
I've been selfish my entire life
I've changed my life I'm now going to
church I found God or I want to live a
different kind of a life I'm no longer
drinking I'm no longer smoking I'm no
longer doing drugs I want to figure out
a way to be a mother one day because I
want to invest into something that's got
high rate of return and I want my
daughters to be proud of me I'm not
proud of my past but I want to change
and I want to set the example for my
kids to know that even a person like me
one day can choose to chain so can
others
there is an element of hero making
machine in that story we need more of
those stories not these types of stores
thank you for being so gracious with
your time as well this has been
absolutely incredible and thank you for
your generosity you invited us last
night to this amazing event I mean that
was incredible with Vivek so that was
great and I just got to say thank you
very much anytime you guys keep doing
what you're doing I I like your style
and I'm excited to see what you guys do
next and when you do do the interview
with Martin make sure you let me know I
want to see it I'm looking forward we
could do this every year we could plan
for uh this time next year I look
forward to I'm going to be in your city
in two days that's right so cool sounds
good thanks guys thank you guys
awesome cool uh thanks
it's not usual that we have an audience
oh